oh les hommes du SWAT s'encouragent une
manière pour eux d'évacuer l'attention
le suspect qu'ils doivent arrêter
seraient armés il est midi le convoi
s'élance en pleine ville je me croirais
presque en pleine zone de guerre à cette
heure les hommes du Soi ont plus de
chance que le suspect soit à son
domicile
mais en pleine journée ils doivent du
coup redoubler de prudence l'opération
doit être aussi rapide que possible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on la surnomme la porte des Amériques
cela fait 10 ans que je n'y ai pas mis
les pieds
Miami l'un des fleurons du tourisme
américain connu dans le monde entier
pour ses séries télévisées Miami Vice
les experts sa plage et ses corps huilés
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on y a cours pour voir jouer
son équipe de basket pour faire la fête
ou pour investir la ville n'a jamais
compté autant de milliardaires
Miami est la ville la plus cosmopolite
des États-Unis l'autre capitale cubaine
ici on parle autant l'espagnol que
l'anglais entre deux bouffées de Havane
et un verre de rhum
[Musique]
mais derrière les gratte-ciel c'est sa
violence qui fait souvent la une de
l'actualité Al Capone Pablo Escobar les
plus grands mafieux de l'histoire ayant
tous ses journées sous fond de trafic
d’alcool et de cocaïne des trafics qui
ont métamorphosé les quartiers de Miami
de nombreux ghettos ou les gangs
s'affrontent lors de réglement de compte
[Musique]
ici les balfuses et les nuits sont
gangrenées par la toxicomanie et la
prostitution
en France je connais le travail des
stups et de la BAC ici il semble que
polis et journaliste est forte à faire
pendant mon séjour je vais découvrir une
ville sous l'emprise des armes à feu ou
les disputes peuvent finir en bain de
sang
je passerai des nuits blanches à traquer
les faits divers avec un journaliste
branché sur les fréquences de la police
je m'essaierai au fusil d'assaut version
force spéciale
des armes que l'on retrouve souvent
entre les mains des trafiquants de
drogue l'autre fléau qui gagne Miami
j'accompagnerai le SWAT dans une
opération antidrogue
j'irai à la rencontre des parias de
Miami
les toxico ravagés par l'héroïne
enfin j'assisterai au verdict de l'un
des plus longs procès de l'histoire
récente de Miami
bienvenue à Magic City la ville de tous
les paradoxes
un passeport pour le crime
pour ma première journée j'ai
rendez-vous loin des gratte-ciel du
centre-ville
[Musique]
à la base hélicoptère de la police du
comté de My Amy day
pour mieux comprendre cette ville
il me faut prendre un peu de hauteur
bonjour Brendan bonjour Carole ravi de
vous rencontrer moi aussi alors on a un
beau programme aujourd'hui oui on va
bien voler aujourd'hui on a un beau
temps de quoi vous montrer une
patrouille dans les herbes du comté de
Miami
et c'est parti pour un petit voyage dans
le ciel de Miami
[Musique]
c'est parti
Miami capitale des Caraïbes un
territoire immense bâti sur une zone de
marée et de dizaines d'îles bordées par
l'océan Atlantique
mégalopole la plus au sud des États-Unis
elle compte 2 millions et demi
d'habitants
avant les gratte-ciels de Downtown je
survole ces banlieues les demeures sans
tennis ou sans piscine sont plutôt rares
la richesse donnerait presque le vertige
ça c'est la ville de Miami au nord
et ça c'est Miami Beach
Miami et sa plage de rêve ces villas de
milliardaires
cela fait plus d'un siècle que les
fortunes se font et se défont ici
certaines ont même marqué son histoire
[Musique]
là où on voit ce petit patio c'est pas
très grand c'est tout blanc
oui c'est là où il y a la piscine foncée
c'était la propriété d'Al Capone
Al Capone l'illustre parrain d'une mafia
qui fait encore la réputation sulfureuse
de Miami
un crime organisé
omniprésent qui a contribué au
développement de la ville une opulence
qui ferait presque oublier la violence
qui règne encore tous les jours
et à ce sujet notre pilote Brendan ne
mâche pas ses mots
Brendan vous diriez que Miami est plus
ou moins violent contrefort
les crimes violents aujourd'hui surtout
dans la ville de Miami ont beaucoup
augmenté
à cause des gangs les homicides ont
augmenté ainsi que les fusillades
mafia gang à Miami la criminalité est
toujours d'actualité
la police est à l'affût car derrière les
tours et la plage un autre Miami existe
et pour le découvrir il faut remettre
les pieds sur terre
retour Adam le centre névralgique de
Miami
les policiers ne sont pas les seuls à
être encore debout il est 1h du matin
j'ai rendez-vous avec un drôle d'oiseau
de nuit
bonsoir Comment ça va ravi de vous
rencontrer moi aussi alors on est prêt
pour une longue nuit dans Miami
son nom est raphio il est journaliste
indépendant
[Musique]
s
des homicides des incendies des
accidents tout ce qui peut intéresser
les chaînes de télévision voilà ce que
je recherche
et je peux venir avec vous oui bien sûr
allez venez
du monde à l'arrière et vous allez
comprendre pourquoi
la voiture de Rafio c'est une vraie tour
de contrôle pour ne rien louper de
l'actualité nocturne il compte 12 radios
branchés sur les fréquences des polices
et des pompiers du comté c'est quand
même assez sereine
[Musique]
ma famille vous manquez jamais rien avec
tout ce bruit
en fait
c'est vrai c'est difficile de tout
entendre mais je me suis habitué et puis
je me repère grâce au code que j'entends
un 30 c'est une fusillade un 49 c'est un
incendie ça m'aide beaucoup
pour aller dans les rues de Miami
commence rafios est à l'affût de la
moindre alerte
ils viennent d'envoyer la brigade
d'urgence ça veut dire qu'un grave
accident de la circulation vient
d'arriver peut-être un délit de fuite ou
quelque chose comme ça
nous nous rendons sur un accident de la
route
enfin encore faut-il qu'on y arrive
parce que regardez la route ce n'est pas
vraiment le truc de rafiot
de ne pas regarder la route alors que
vous conduisez
un million de choses à faire en même
temps
j'ai 12 radios à surveiller et puis je
dois programmer mon GPS aussi
alors les hommes peuvent donc faire
plusieurs choses en même temps je
suppose vous êtes l'exception
peut-être c'est possible
[Musique]
mais c'est pas celui qui nous intéresse
ah ok ça c'est bon
ça a l'air pas mal
[Musique]
pour l'instant aucun périmètre de
sécurité n'a été installé
rafiot peut s'approcher au plus près
[Musique]
une voiture de sport aurait heurté un
abri de bus et finit sa course au nord
il y a quelqu'un à terre par la barre
près de la Redbus il y a quelqu'un à
terre
le choc a été très violent
l'abribus est pulvérisée
laissant peu de chance à un homme qui
s'y était installé
je crois que quelqu'un est mort juste là
sous l'arrêt de bus
à côté du fauteuil roulant vous le voyez
la victime reste immobile son fauteuil
roulant a été écrasé
le conducteur de la voiture de sport
semble
mais celui que Rafio croyait mort finit
par bouger il est bien en vie les
pompiers parviennent même à le relever
bonne nouvelle pas tant que ça pour le
reporter
il y a un homme en fauteuil roulant tué
par un chauffard et ça ça aurait fait la
une en principe
heureusement pour cet homme il est
vivant malheureusement pour moi il n'est
pas mort
une mauvaise nouvelle pas si sûr les
États-Unis raffolent des histoires qui
finissent bien et raffiot a dégoté un
témoin de soi cet homme a tout vu
qu'en pensez-vous le gars est vivant il
a même l'air de bien aller
franchement je suis stupéfait qu'il soit
vivant c'est presque un miracle
un de ces miracles qu'on aimerait voir
plus souvent
et voilà qui fera la une d'un journal
télévisé local dès le lendemain matin
une soirée plutôt rentable pour rafios
car avant que je ne le rejoigne notre
journaliste a eu le temps de filmer une
seconde histoire qui s'est moins bien
terminé il nous montre ses images sur sa
caméra
la scène se déroule dans un quartier du
Nord Miami
dans cet appartement un homme a mis fin
à ses jours avec son revolver après
avoir tenté de tuer sa compagne
la jeune femme sentir avec un genou
pulvérisé mais ses jours ne sont pas en
danger
sa famille est encore sous le choc c'est
sa mère qui a donné la l'air
je décide de faire un tour à Liberty
City au nord de Miami c'est dans ce
quartier que le drame a eu lieu il y a
quatre à peine
ici 100% de la population est noire des
habitants originaires d'Haïti de
Jamaïque de Trinidad venus goûter au
rêve Floridiens mais rattrapé par une
toute autre réalité celle du chômage et
des maisons abandonnées
liberticity la ville de la liberté
certains noms ont un goût amer
[Musique]
alors nous y sommes
le quartier semble avoir retrouvé son
calme comme si rien ne s'était passé
c'est pourtant derrière cette porte que
s'est déroulé le drame
kentranis et son ami Nakia était
ensemble depuis 10 ans
c'est en pleine nuit qu'il aurait tenté
de tuer sa femme il a ensuite retourné
son arme contre lui
le couple vivait ici avec trois enfants
au pied de l'immeuble je retrouve la mer
de la femme blessée
Elisa s'occupe de ses petits-enfants
c'est son père qui s'est tué
son père oui
c'est lui qui s'est suicidé après avoir
tiré sur ma fille
et il a vu quelque chose
il a vu quelque chose
non non il dormait mais deux petits
enfants dormaient ils n'ont rien vu
non il sait rien
je vais aller nettoyer
je suis Elisa les tâches de sang
tapissent les marches de la maison
voilà la scène de crime
la scène s'est déroulée dans la chambre
à coucher juste en face de celle des
enfants
voilà je dois nettoyer tout ça
le sang a recouvert tout le sol
d'habitude il allait comment là il était
déprimé je ne sais pas ça fait un moment
que je ne le voyais pas
parce que c'est un acte désespéré
ma fille ne m'a rien dit fallait qu'elle
aille à l'hôpital elle m'a juste dit
maman il m'a tiré dans la jambe et après
il s'est tué d'une balle dans la tête
pour Elisa rien explique le geste de son
gendre il était âgé de 37 ans
c'était quelqu'un de bien oui très
gentil
je l'aimais comme un fils
il était très gentil
il faisait partie de la famille depuis
10 ans mais avait-il des problèmes
d'alcool ou de drogue
non jamais de problème
les raisons du drame resteront un
mystère pour moi sa fille la jeune femme
à la robe rayée tout juste rentrée de
l'hôpital n'a pas voulu répondre à mes
questions
je sais juste que kentranis et Nakia
était tous les deux au chômage et que
lui détenait son propre revolver à la
maison
en Floride une personne sur quatre
possède une arme à feu c'est l'état le
plus armé des États-Unis
ici il suffit d'être majeur et d'avoir
un casier judiciaire sans lourd de
condamnation pour pouvoir en acheter une
à Miami on compte des dizaines d'armurer
mais aussi des stands de tir
j'ai rendez-vous dans l'un d'entre eux
son nom est évocateur le Loken load ce
qui veut dire Paris attiré
et oui à Miami on assume sa passion pour
les armes
bonjour bonjour moi c'est Stacy prête
pour votre expérience de tir au fusil
ma monitrice est une ancienne marine
américaine elle va m'initier au fusil
automatique dans ce stand de tir branché
c'est très beau ici c'est très très à la
mode c'est le style de Miami
d'habitude un stand de tir c'est sombre
et pas très cool
nous on voulait que ce soit accueillant
pour les touristes et pour tout le monde
qui veut se détendre
donc nous avons notre menu comme si on
était au restaurant avec toutes nos
armes au choix et des packages à 3 ou 4
armes
vous pouvez choisir une de ces formules
ou bien créer la vôtre
chinois
et ça et ça c'est pour les enfants
ils doivent être âgés entre 10 et 13 ans
accompagné bien sûr
ils viennent s'exercer au tir
il y a beaucoup d'enfants qui viennent
à leurs parents je veux tirer je veux
tirer
sont totalement banalisées elle ferait
presque figure de jouer
des armes pourtant bien réel
ici le fusil des Marines américains
celui qui a tué Ben Laden ou encore la
célèbre AK-47 de Scarface
des armes que je vais essayer tout de
suite j'ai déjà tiré mais jamais au
fusil automatique
donc on va commencer avec un MP5 c'est
le fusil militaire le plus connu au
monde
votre main droite là et votre gauche ici
l'arme est encore verrouillée bien je la
déverrouille coup par coup allez-y
vous avez tiré dans le même trou
qu'en pensez-vous
mes lunettes ça donne chaud
ok
non vous êtes très bonne pour une
première fois les femmes sont toujours
les meilleures
mais mon entraînement ne s'arrête pas là
on passe à la gamme supérieure
j'ai peur
non mais ne vous inquiétez pas je reste
juste derrière vous
qu'est-ce que je fais maintenant vous
appuyez pendant trois secondes
[Musique]
c'est trop ouais c'est trop je préfère
c'est prenant
tu as peur avant de tirer ça fait ça
fait on a peur de du recul on a peur de
ce que ça va impliquer ça sent les
odeur aussi c'est
voilà la cible il est mort
sur ce corps
merci beaucoup
si je suis impressionné il y en a
d'autres qui le sont beaucoup moins
question d'habitude visiblement cette
jeune fille essaye le plus puissant
fusil d'assaut du monde
j'enlève la sécurité je me mets derrière
vous
alors c'était bien super c'est super
marrant j'adore ça
le problème c'est Camille a mis les
armes à feu ne sont pas qu'un jeu elle
tue tous les jours
fusillade réglement de compte ou cas de
légitime défense remplissent les
rubriques faits divers des journaux
télévisés
en France on compte 600 homicides par an
mais rien qu'à Miami il y en a près de
400 80% d'entre eux sont causés par des
armes à feu
tout me ramène encore à Liberty City le
ghetto du Nord Miami derrière le ciel
bleu et les palmiers les armes pullulent
mais cette fois-ci de manière illégale
les gangs font la loi dans le quartier
les rafales d'armes automatiques liées
au règlement de compte ils sont
fréquentes et les meurtres par balle
perdu aussi
sera mon guide
ici il y a eu plus de 30 homicides rien
que ces deux dernières années
pin's est un ancien membre de gang il a
46 ans et connaît le quartier par cœur
[Musique]
un quartier au surnom évocateur Polk and
haricots le plat des pauvres par
excellence aux États-Unis
un quartier minuscule de seulement 5 rue
où les balfuse
[Musique]
sur les 30 derniers homicides dans le
quartier 17 sont liés des balles perdues
17 victimes innocentes auxquelles fleurs
peluche et t-shirt en hommage ici on
appelle ça un mémorial
grant 18 ans elle était maman d'un
enfant de 3 mois
elle a pris une balle d'AK47 dans le
coup juste ici
d'une voiture
l'autre fille a été tuée d'une balle en
plein torax
elle est morte au coin de la rue après
avoir couru quelques mètres
j'étais chez ma sœur juste à côté ce
soir-là et j'ai entendu les coups de feu
boum boum boum boum boum boum boum j'ai
dit à ma sœur
et que fait la police rien de toute
façon personne ne parle les meurtres
comme ça des fusillades
c'est la marque des gangs
donc tout le monde se tait ils ont peur
des représailles
ce double missile est vieux de 4 mois
quelques mètres plus loin un autre
t-shirt est accroché
[Musique]
dans ces quelques rues me donne le
tournis un mémorial n'est jamais long à
trouver
Micheline 62 ans ils l'ont tué ici en
pleine rue il y a deux semaines
elle a été atteinte dans le ventre il
visait quelqu'un d'autre
il faut avoir des yeux dans le dos ici
mais surtout faut pas traîner par là
la liberté le calme n'est qu'une
apparence la tension règne tout le temps
notre caméra attire vite l'attention des
dealers
c'est sans doute le cas de cet homme en
rouge qui cache à peine son révolvevert
mais aussi des toxicomanes plutôt
nerveux
j'ai mal mec je suis grave en colère
tout me rend fou
allez on y va
ce n'est pas à l'aise il préfère que
l'on parte il sait qu'ici tout peut
dégénérer très vite
à Liberty City ne se passe pas un mois
sans homicide et dans 90% des cas les
assassins ne sont jamais arrêtés
une affaire a récemment fait plus de
bruit que les autres
une famille pleure sa fille de 17 ans
tuée par une balle perdue en plein parc
la jeune quai mouria Garner tuée d'une
balle perdue une affaire aux airs de
déjà-vu qui trouve son originalité dans
le combat d'une femme Régina la
belle-mère de la victime
la violence doit cesser des innocents
perdent leur vie
je retrouve Régina 6 semaines après son
passage à la télévision elle est
accompagnée de ses enfants
c'est le parc ou notre bien-aimé qui
m'auriagarner a perdu la vie
elle était assise juste là sur le banc
discutaient là près du terrain de basket
à traverser le parking
et a commencé à tirer sur ces deux
jeunes
une balade directement traversée le
terrain de jeu
et a frappé qui mouria en pleine tête
elle est morte sur le coup
sur les 80 personnes qui étaient là
personne n'a rien vu
c'est presque devenu banal
quand ils entendent des coups de feu ah
ok c'est juste des coups de feu
ils s'en fiche c'est presque devenu
normal
à chaque fois que quelqu'un meurt sous
les balles la loi du silence s'abat sur
Liberty City et ça Régina n'en peut plus
aujourd'hui elle a décidé d'organiser
une marche pour stopper la violence
[Musique]
apporte-moi les fleurs
les fleurs sont prêtes les t-shirts
aussi
des t-shirts en forme David recherche
avec photos de quémoria et promesse de
récompense à la clé
c'est un jour que vous n'allez jamais
oublier les enfants
l'impact de cette marche doit vous
motiver pour devenir des leaders dans
votre communauté
c'est de la paroisse Baptiste du
quartier celle du Mont calvaire que la
marche partira
la famille d'origine a est au grand
complet
[Musique]
PC
c'est ma préférée
c'est la mère de kimouria la grand-mère
de keymoria et son petit frère un grand
garçon
alors votre famille est très unie yes oh
oui oh oui nous le sommes vraiment
unis dans le souvenir et dans la lutte
pour la vérité
Régine a et rejointe par d'autres
familles de victimes
c'est la mère de zamari
[Musique]
il a été tué
au total cette famille de victimes ont
répondu à l'appel de Regina
Shawn combien de temps ça fait pour ton
fils un mois
ils ont tous perdu un fils une fille un
petit-fils tous morts de bal perdu
je vous remercie d'être venu oui on doit
être des exemples pour les autres villes
les autres communautés
cette loi du silence doit cesser on doit
se serrer les coudes on doit se battre
pour nos enfants
nous formons une famille
montrons l'exemple à nos enfants
ouvrez vos portes
Martin Luther King n'avait pas peur de
sortir de chez lui
[Applaudissements]
nous devons obtenir justice
pas seulement pour ceux que nous avons
perdu
mais pour tous ceux qui ont perdu leur
bien-aimés
parce qu'il y en aura d'autres
vous pouvez en être sûr
on est une famille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les patrouilles de police sont prêtes à
escorter les marcheurs
Regina elle distribue ses roses
et je retrouve Vince
représentant la paroisse il est venu
prêter main forte pour la marque
[Musique]
je suis si fatigué il marche vite
sont à peine une soixantaine à défiler
un nombre infime mais qu'importe c'est
la première fois qu'un tel événement a
lieu dans le quartier
[Musique]
la première fois que des manifestants
osent marcher dans le port Kennedy
[Musique]
la marche il trouve quelques supporters
et même d'autres familles de victimes
[Musique]
quant à ceux qui aux à peine sortir de
chez eux des fleurs leur sont
distribuées en signe de fraternité
[Musique]
des fleurs qui tapissent aussi les
mémorial du quartier
on doit éradiquer les armes si vous êtes
d'accord répétez après moi il faut
stopper les fusillades dans notre
quartier
c'est ici que nous vivons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la marche de réginette touche à sa fin
une première victoire en attendant que
les meurtriers de sa belle-fille soient
arrêtés le problème c'est Camille ami
70% des homicides ne sont jamais résolus
[Musique]
bienvenue sur Chrome stopers une
émission hebdomadaire qui vient en aide
aux familles de victimes un carton pour
cette chaîne locale qui attire en
moyenne 100000 téléspectateurs ici la
star c'est lui bienvenue sur Chrome
stopers Sud Floride je suis Dick Masters
je retrouve Richard Masten dans les
bureaux de crimes stoppers un producteur
pas tout à fait comme les autres Richard
a servi pendant 25 ans en tant que
détective à la brigade criminelle de la
police de Miami
alors
ce que nous faisons c'est donner aux
personnes la possibilité d'apporter des
informations sur des cas de meurtres non
résolus de manière anonyme et sans
parler directement à la police
pour cela ils sont récompensés 300
dollars par information valable
on résout beaucoup de meurtres grâce à
cette émission mais pas tous
malheureusement
mais ça reste un outil indispensable
un outil très particulier aujourd'hui
Richard enregistre la partie témoignage
de l'émission
les caméras sont prêtes
[Musique]
l'interview d'un père dont le fils est
mort il y a 18 mois
Richard en bel Junior avait 21 ans il a
été tué d'une balle dans la tête à bout
portant aujourd'hui l'enquête est dans
l'impasse la police a besoin
d'informations pour motiver les
potentiels témoins à appeler crime
stoppers Richard joue la carte sensible
si c'était la dernière fois que vous
parliez à votre fils pour lui dire quoi
je lui dirai je t'aime Richard je t'aime
tellement
il n'y a même pas de mots pour te dire
combien je t'aime et combien je
t'aimerai toujours
que diriez-vous aux gens qui savent
quelque chose et qui se taisent
car c'est la chose la plus juste à faire
votre enfant pourrait être la prochaine
victime
pour moi c'est parfait
ok rien à ajouter
mon nom est Carole bonjour ça vous
dérange si je vous
pose une
juste
là pour parler de votre fils
mais votre femme n'est pas là pourquoi
elle n'en est pas capable
c'est trop difficile pour elle
je dois je dois être assez fort pour
nous deux
et vraiment c'est au-dessus de ses
forces
pour vous exactement
pour optimiser les chances d'obtenir des
informations l'émission s'appuie aussi
sur des scènes de reconstitution
ça se joue à l'endroit exact où Richard
a été tué avec le détective chargé de
l'enquête en personne
[Musique]
le suspect marché derrière la voiture il
est parti de là
il avait l'air très louche le témoin a
insisté là-dessus il marchait comme ça
les explications sont précises les
réalisateurs de l'émission écoutent
attentivement les recommandations
dans ce cas là vous êtes une sorte de
conseillé technique dans cette affaire
j'essaie de leur retranscrire au mieux
ce que je sais et vous savez tout de
cette affaire non pas tout
le peu de choses que nous savons c'est
que la victime était en voiture le long
de cette allée et que quelqu'un suivait
cette voiture
on a une description du suspect des
rouilles pour le reste nous ne savons
pas
la scène est placée sous surveillance
policière il ne faudrait pas que les
voisins s'inquiètent tout doit paraître
aussi réel que possible le comédien en
blanc c'est notre tueur lui notre
victime le casting est complet mais il
reste un petit détail à régler
la reconstitution du crime du fils de
Richard va avoir lieu et alors la
production vient nous informer qu'il
avait une bonne et une mauvaise nouvelle
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que la
voiture ne correspondait pas visiblement
et ne correspond pas à la voiture
impliquée dans le cas et la bonne
nouvelle c'est que notre voiture
correspond donc nous allons aider la
production de nous allons échanger les
voitures
[Musique]
le tueur de Richard serait une de ses
connaissances
c'est un témoin habitant derrière la
haie d'arbre qui a repéré ce drôle de
manège et appelait la police avance
avance encore
avant toujours sous bon conseil la
voiture avance jusqu'au lieu exact du
crime là où le corps a été retrouvé
Richard est mort d'une balle dans la
tête
[Musique]
des meurtriers bon d'accord on fait de
la fiction mais si cela peut aider à
raviver la mémoire d'un voisin ici ou là
si ça aide à trouver ces criminels on
sert à quelque chose
ce programme a permis à deux
informations de se faire connaître et de
faire avancer l'enquête Richard humble
junior
jusqu'à aujourd'hui une émission sur
quatre permet de retrouver les assassins
de ses canons
Miami me réserve encore beaucoup de
surprises
j'accompagnerai le SWAT le GIGN version
américaine au cours de l'arrestation
d'un dealer
je rencontrerai des junkies qui se
shootent à l'héroïne en plein ghetto je
déambulerai dans les quartiers chauds de
Miami avec notre oiseau de nuit raffiaux
le journaliste
et j'assisterai au verdict d'un procès
pour assassinat
[Musique]
depuis que je suis arrivée à Miami j'en
aurai presque oublié qu'elle est située
au bord de l'océan dans les Caraïbes
[Musique]
le kit d'entendre et les ghettos pour
les beaux quartiers car si Miami est
célèbre c'est grâce à son île Miami
Beach
[Musique]
Miami Beach c'est une plage sans fin qui
attire les vacanciers du monde entier
une eau à 25 degrés même en janvier
[Musique]
un décor de cinéma où les façades art
déco se succèdent
ou villa et yacht rivalise de luxe
[Musique]
bonjour Philippe bonjour
Félix est un promoteur immobilier
français le guide parfait pour découvrir
ce monde un monde que l'on ne peut
effleurer qu'en bateau
à Miami le contraste entre riche et
pauvre et saisissons la richesse doit se
voir mais de loin
les villas sont situés sur des dizaines
d'îles du coup l'océan joue une parfaite
barrière de sécurité
donc ça c'est une île privée qui
s'appelle plus sur Island où tous les
appartements une vue extraordinaire de
ce côté c'est la vue sur downtown on a
un peu l'impression vraiment d'être dans
son club privé il y a des très belles
piscines
Félix en termes de sécurité là sur l'île
si on débarque il se passe quoi
vous pouvez pas prendre le ferry sans
savoir qui vous êtes et vous allez ils
savent tout exactement ce qu'on fait
donc il y a aucun aucun incident à 100%
aussi
30 degrés toute l'année une position
géographique exceptionnelle aujourd'hui
tout le monde veut avoir sa maison ici
là maintenant on arrive les maisons qui
ont le plus de valeur parce que la vue
est très ouverte
c'est ce que vous avez la maison des
budgets
l'ancienne maison de Jennifer Lopez la
maison de Matt Damon
pas mal de célébrités
qui compte seulement 30 villages Lille
la plus privée de Miami et forcément la
plus sécurisée
la voiture de police
impossible d'y pénétrer à moins d'être
invité par un habitant même Félix ne
peut pas y entrer il y a pourtant habité
et conclut une belle affaire
à un an et demi
exactement c'est vendu pour 47 millions
de dollars
il y a un an et demi à l'époque c'était
un record et je crois que c'est toujours
le record
sur la gauche faisait un pavillon
principal le masto bédo métaux au
deuxième niveau c'est une mastering qui
fait 300 mètres carrés
14 chambres
14 cuisine placée sous bonne garde
la les gardiens nous ont à l'oeil
sur la piscine à piscine
regarde aussi
la police nous suit depuis un petit
moment
30 personnes qui habitent sur l'île et
il y a 17 officiers de police pour
protéger le chiffre est stupéfiant à
Liberty City il y a 100 policiers pour
50 000 habitants et zéro caméra de
surveillance mais en fait la vraie
sécurité c'est pas la police c'est la
technologie vous voyez vous voyez là la
colonne noir là ça ce sont des rayons si
je voulais rentrer sur la maison
automatiquement je suis capté c'est
relié à la police on peut pas pénétrer
à Miami se protéger tourne à l'obsession
il faut dire que les plus grands mafieux
de l'histoire y ont élu domicile
je retrouve la maison d'Al Capone alors
la maison de spécial c'est que comme il
voulait se protéger un petit peu vous
voulez pas avoir trop de gens qui le
regardent il avait construit un petit
pavillon carrément sur l'eau c'est le
petit Paillon pavillon blanc qui lui
donnait un petit peu de privacité
de la maison est derrière
Al Capone voulait sans doute se protéger
des regards mais aussi des balles
la maison rose la toute vieille c'est
l'ancienne maison de Pablo Escobar
qui a été tué il y a quelques années
c'est Miami a inspiré tant de films et
de séries télévisées ce n'est pas par
hasard
quand je suis arrivé 80 82 c'était
c'était une ville de gangster quand même
c'était il y avait une très gros trafic
de drogue la mafia colombienne était là
enfin c'était c'était assez inouï quoi
enfin moi à l'époque j'avais donc des
boutiques de prêt-à-porter et c'était
courant d'avoir des des clients qui
arrivaient avec des balises et qui vous
payez avec des liasses de cash ils
allaient dans les cabines des feuillages
ils ouvrent la valise et vous voyez des
des millions de dollars dans une valise
et on était payé comme ça
des millions de dollars gagnés grâce au
trafic de drogue cocaïne héroïne
marijuana
depuis des décennies le port de Miami
est le point d'entrée principale de la
drogue en provenance des Caraïbes et
d'Amérique du Sud
une drogue qui se cache notamment dans
les milliers de containers déchargé
chaque jour
les garde-côtes font bien quelques
saisies records la plus récente est de
110 millions de dollars
mais les flux sont incontrôlables et la
drogue inonde les rues de Miami
[Musique]
je me rends à aïalia un quartier
populaire à majorité hispanique située
au nord-ouest de la ville
ici l'anglais disparaît des panneaux
publicitaires c'est l'espagnol qui est
de rigueur
j'ai rendez-vous à l'arrière d'un
supermarché avec le SWAT de Miami Dade
le GIGN version américaine gros muscle
et gros calibre une trentaine d'hommes
et sur le pont
au programme du jour l'arrestation d'un
trafiquant de drogue approchez-vous
pour mener l'opération le sergent Bruce
et ses 15 années de Swat
la maison est située à l'angle de
plusieurs avenues
c'est un territoire particulier les gars
et le sergent Sierra
d'autres infos
c'est un mandat d'arrêt contre un
trafiquant de marijuana mais il y a sans
doute d'autres drogues le suspect connu
on a une photo de lui
sa mère peut-être à la maison ou pas
faut pas se fier à la présence de
voiture ou non devant la maison
donc faites attention à elle
les hommes du Swatch s'encouragent une
manière pour eux d'évacuer la tension le
suspect qu'ils doivent arrêter serait
armer
il est midi le convoi s'élance en pleine
ville je me croirais presque en pleine
zone de guerre
à cette heure les hommes du SWAT ont
plus de chances que le suspect soit à
son domicile
mais en pleine journée ils doivent du
coup redoubler de prudence
[Musique]
l'opération doit être aussi rapide que
possible
les brigades antinerco attendent que les
soins trouvent le suspect un suspect qui
n'est pas seul première personne
interpellé sa petite amie
écoute-moi
assieds-toi viens ensuite sa mère qui
tourne de l'oeil immédiatement
on s'occupe d'elle t'inquiète pas on
s'occupe d'elle
[Musique]
alors que la petite amie est éloignée de
la Seine le médecin du swatte s'occupe
de la mère du suspect
vous inquiétez pas c'est la police
madame
le suspect le voici
on a été
cueilli une résistance
les hommes peuvent commencer la
perquisition
et la surprise est de taille
5000 dollars de marijuana
7000 dollars de cocaïne et 5000 dollars
d'héroïne sans oublier une moto flambant
neuve
l'opération est un succès pour l'équipe
du sergent russe
plus vite on entre plus vite on contrôle
les lieux et plus on évite des actes de
violence ou des fusillades
[Musique]
même s'il y a eu un peu de confusion ils
ont bien compris ce que nous faisions
ici
les gars et bonne fin de journée
des interventions comme celle-ci les
souhaitent en font tous les jours à
Miami cette fois aucun coup de feu n'a
été tiré mais il y a souvent des blessés
par balles au cours de ces opérations
une autre nuit se profile
et avec elle tous les excès qui
caractérisent Miami
[Musique]
faites alcool strip-tease le tout arrosé
de drogue
[Musique]
ce soir je retrouverai fio mon traqueur
de faits divers
[Musique]
il m'a donné rendez-vous à l'ouest de la
ville les brigades antinarco ont fait
une drôle de découverte
[Musique]
là j'ai du bon matos
ça va être une bonne histoire
ils ont trouvé une piscine ou plutôt une
supposée piscine transformée en
laboratoire de drogue
dans cette maison d'un quartier
résidentiel sans histoire un nouveau
type de plantation de marijuana vient
d'être trouvé
nous n'avons pas le droit d'y entrer
mais nous avons confié notre caméra au
policiers
une vingtaine de plans de marijuana
cachés dans le fond d'une piscine
recouverte par une dalle de béton
et voilà ce que cela donne de
l'extérieur
pour les hélicoptères de la police
impossible de repérer ce laboratoire
caché sous ses sofa
pour y accéder une simple trappe était
reliée à la maison un phénomène d'un
genre nouveau pour les policiers
ce type de plantation très sophistiqué
est très rare c'est seulement la
deuxième fois qu'on en trouve
des piscines converties en plantation
donc nous devons alerter nos citoyens
pour qu'ils soient vigilants s'il voit
une piscine se construire car il est
possible qu'il construise plutôt un labo
de marijuana
et pour sensibiliser la population quoi
de mieux que les caméras de télévision
c'est de l'herbe tout ça
vous pouvez ouvrir les sacs qu'on voit
les feuilles
une partie de la saisie est aussitôt
présentée aux médias
000 dollars
mais pour les caméras le clou du
spectacle consiste à pouvoir filmer le
couple de trafiquant qui gérait la
plantation
[Musique]
des Cubains récemment immigrés à Miami
ils vivent dans cette maison depuis 9
mois et disent ne pas être au courant de
ce trafic
le lendemain les policiers découvriront
trois autres laboratoires comme celui-ci
tous appartenant au même réseau valeur
des saisies 1 million de dollars
Rafio a vendu l'histoire à deux chaînes
de télévision il leur envoie directement
les images depuis sa voiture grâce à son
ordinateur
le problème c'est que la soirée
s'annonce chargée
on a une fusillade
il faut y aller
[Musique]
une fusillade en plein port Kennedy's à
Liberty City
ils ont envoyé une deuxième ambulance il
y a deux victimes de blessés par balle
[Musique]
Rafio est un homme pressé
et lorsqu'il arrive sur les lieux il ne
passe pas inaperçu
je suis à peine arrivé que la police
annonce par radio que je suis là les
flics ont vu ma voiture arriver tout le
monde le connaît ici
comme d'habitude Rafio arrive en premier
il restera même tout seul les médias
n'aiment pas venir ici en pleine nuit
[Musique]
ils ont tiré à travers c'est leur marque
de fabrique regardez il tire à travers
les vitres
la première personne visée a juste été
touchée superficiellement à la tête
ça c'est de la chance il a eu de la
chance
la deuxième en revanche est dans un état
jugé plus sérieux elle a reçu de balles
dans le ventre
il y a beaucoup de fusillades dans ce
genre de coin à malfamé
de compte
c'est un classique
d'après la police ce règlement de compte
est lié au trafic de drogue qui sévit
dans le quartier
ici on vit dans l'angoisse de
représailles et on supporte mal la
présence de notre caméra
vire ta caméra de là toi
Liberty City la base arrière des gangs
de Miami n'est pas très hospitalière à
cette heure de la nuit
mais d'après Rafio il y a pire encore
je vous emmène à overtown
c'est la jungle là-bas
et comme on va dans la jungle
interdit de nourrir les animaux ou de
sortir un seul doigt de la voiture
over Town le quartier numéro 1 du trafic
de drogue à Miami un ghetto situé juste
au nord du quartier des affaires
la pauvreté il y a élu domicile ici on
est plus près du cauchemar que du rêve
américain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gens qui traînent là ce sont tous
des dealers ils attendent des clients
regardez si on ralentit ils sortent de
partout
cocaïne craque héroïne overtown est un
supermarché à ciel ouvert
des entrepreneurs il y a beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs à Miami
tout le monde veut faire son business
souvent ils sont à vélo ils livrent
directement et surtout il s'enfuit plus
rapidement
ils sont tous armés et ont de la drogue
sur eux
[Musique]
reste dans la voiture et ne sort surtout
pas
des armes qui finissent par se faire
entendre dans le quartier
un réglement de compte vient juste
d'avoir lieu
vous voyez le camion de lacrim là-bas
une personne vient d'être tuée mais
raphyo fait demi-tour de toute façon il
a gagné sa nuit et puis les règlements
de compte entre dealers n'intéresse pas
les médias
[Musique]
cela fait plus de 20 ans que la drogue a
élu domicile à over Town ici le métro
s'arrête là où commence la misère
[Musique]
la police veille mais la tâche est
immense
dans ce quartier à 95% noir deux
populations se croisent les dealers et
les toxicos shooter
des ombres discrètes comme des mirages
un détail trahit les consommateurs
leurs couleurs de peau
les seuls blancs du quartier ce sont les
toxicos
[Musique]
John est un ancien héroïnomène devenu
travailleur social
il sera notre guide dans ce monde au
code bien précis
regardez là c'est une passe une
négociation en direct
pour se payer une dose la jeune femme
propose à ce taxi un service sexuel en
échange d'argent nous sommes vite
repérés
il a perdu le business allons-y il n'est
pas content pardon
les jeunes gens ont cru que nous étions
des policiers
les jeunes femmes toxicoman sont obligés
de se prostituer pour acheter une dose
d'héroïne
elles ne peuvent pas faire un autre job
comme par exemple rester une journée
dans une boutique ça c'est impossible
elles sont malades
[Musique]
depuis quelques années l'héroïne a fait
son retour à Miami c'est dans les squats
d'overtown comme celui-ci que les plus
accros vient de s'injecter leur dose
nous nous posons en face pour observer
un drôle de manège
[Musique]
ce bâtiment où elle va c'est ce qu'on
appelle une plante
un endroit où on se défonce si vous
préférez ça secret de manière spontanée
c'est quasi impossible pour la police de
fermer ce genre d'endroit
le balai est incessant cette plante est
tenue par trois dealers nous décidons
quand même d'approcher l'une des
toxicomanes qui vient d'en sortir
allez on y va
bonjour je peux te parler une minute je
suis John c'est quoi ton nom
Erin et je me défonce depuis 7 ans
est un nulle part pour aller non c'est
ici que je trouve mon héroïne
si tu veux essayer d'avoir un lit en
cure de dans un toc
non c'est vraiment trop difficile il
regarde les toxico comme des poubelles
regardez mes marques sur les bras je
meurs de froid je tremble
je ne peux pas me laver
j'ai pas dormi depuis 17 heures je suis
glacée
je sais qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
place disponibles mais si quelqu'un te
trouve une place tu irais ou tu en as
marre de tout ça
j'en ai marre
pourquoi je ne te juge pas
je crois qu'il n'y a plus d'espoir pour
moi vraiment tu as quel âge
25 ans
d'autres questions elle se sent vraiment
pas bien on est désolé au revoir
[Musique]
sans savoir si nous la revérons à 25 ans
et cette année de toxicomanie on vit en
sursis
en prenant leur dose tous les
toxicomanes ont le projet d'embrasser
Dieu c'est une expression il s'agit
d'approcher la mort le plus près
possible jusqu'au point ultime
cette fille c'est comme si c'était moi
il y a quelques années
j'en étais au point où j'en avais
tellement assez que j'espérais presque
mourir d'une overdose
j'étais fatigué de vivre sur cette terre
plus longtemps
l'année dernière dans le comté de Miami
l'héroïne a fait 62 morts
ce chiffre a doublé en deux ans
les toxicomanes sont arrangés dans la
catégorie des parias que cette ville
fait tout pour ignorer
un homme refuse cette fatalité
et c'est au tribunal pour mineur de
Miami qu'on le trouve
les toxicomanes les plus jeunes de la
ville défile ici chez le juge Orlando
Prescott
il occupe le poste de juge pour enfants
depuis 14 ans
quel est l'ordre du jour ce matin on va
suivre l'application des peines
il y a beaucoup de problèmes de drogue
ici ah oui oui beaucoup quel type de
drogue
[Musique]
tous les médicaments utilisés comme
drogue comme les anxiolytiques
et on assiste aussi au retour de
l'héroïne
tous les mineurs qui comparaissent ici
sont inscrits à un programme très strict
de désintoxication
mais l'ambiance y est à l'encouragement
[Applaudissements]
oui très bien le papa est content
ah oui très content super je suis très
content
ta mère dit que ça se passe très très
bien à la maison concernant l'école
présence quotidienne pas d'absence
injustifiée ni punition c'est génial ça
couvre-feu thérapie suivi scolaire
pendant 6 mois ces jeunes toxico sont
astrains à une discipline de fer pour
éviter de replonger
c'est tes potes avec qui tu traînais tu
ne traîne plus avec non c'est fini
de notre programme tu dois changer trois
choses dans ta vie les gens les lieux et
les choses en gros tes anciens potes les
lieux où tu traînais est-ce que tu y
faisais c'est ça qui crée le changement
on est très fier de toi sincèrement
fier au point même de distribuer des
cadeaux
fermez vos yeux et mélangez tu veux
qu'il prenne un coupon une carte une
carte
un taco belle taco belle 10 dollars et
en plus c'est ton favoris
programme sévère de désintoxication
ici les jeunes des fils avec le handicap
leur progrès leur bonne nouvelle
j'ai une super motivation pour finir ce
programme maintenant je vais devenir
papa dans 6 mois un nouveau challenge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais il arrive parfois que le juge est à
prendre des décisions plus graves ce
jeune homme a essayé toutes les drogues
aujourd'hui ses parents sont aux abonnés
absents ils vivent chez sa grand-mère en
probation il ne respecterait plus le
couvre-feu
comment ça se passe avec ta grand-mère
elle se plaint de moi elle dit que je ne
suis pas ses ordres
le problème c'est que j'ai des
obligations
et quand il m'arrive de rentrer en
retard je lui dis toujours pourquoi
est-ce que je faisais
franchement je dois te placer pour que
tu progresses mieux Michael je suis
désolé écoute nous serons toujours là
pour toi ce n'est pas une punition c'est
le contraire
promis que si je faisais bien les choses
je sais pas quoi vous dire Monsieur
Prescott non vas-y explique-toi
à quelle heure rentres-tu à la maison
honnêtement pas plus tard que 10 heures
10 heures du quoi du soir et je t'ai mis
en quoi en résidence surveiller oui
c'est ça du coup comment tu peux me dire
que tu fais bien les choses je t'ai
promis des choses mais attends pas si tu
rentres tout le temps en retard chez toi
regarde-moi
mes progrès vous vous en fichez j'en ai
fait et ça ne compte pas j'étais censé
rebondir avec cette thérapie et je m'en
sens capable ok attends attends
ok tout le monde sortez s'il vous plaît
nous sommes priés d'arrêter de tourner
le juge Prescott veut entendre seul ce
jeune visiblement déstabilisé par son
placement au foyer
je retrouve le juge dans son bureau un
peu plus tard
alors pourquoi avoir choisi de devenir
juge pour enfants
j'ai croisé beaucoup de jeunes adultes
délinquance les crimes sans jamais
vraiment mûrir
j'en pouvais plus de voir tous ces
jeunes aller en prison
je voulais tout faire pour les empêcher
d'en prendre le chemin alors j'ai changé
de voix
je ne peux pas faire grand-chose pour
quelqu'un de 25 ans mais pour un mineur
de 15 ça je peux vous êtes connus pour
être un juge plutôt sévère
je suis connu pour être équitable les
jeunes et leurs parents savent que je
ferai tout pour corriger leur mauvaise
habitude et leur éviter la case prison
le jour où je les envoie en camp de
redressement les jeunes savent que je
leur ai donné toutes les chances de
l'éviter
donc en général
si je dois les mettre en détention ça se
passe bien ils savent bien que le juge
prescote est juste
après j'explique toujours à ces jeunes
que je les soutiens que je les apprécie
que je leur souris
mais qui ne profite pas de ma
gentillesse pour me faire un coup dans
le dos
[Musique]
mais juste le juge Prescott aime donner
sa chance aux jeunes délinquants
[Musique]
mais il est décrit que Miami ne pardonne
pas
[Musique]
ces hommes ont été condamnés pour
exhibitionnistes attouchement
détournement de mineurs ou viol on les
appelle les sexophendes alors sorti de
prison et pendant toute la durée de leur
liberté conditionnelle la loi en Floride
leur interdit de se loger à moins de 800
mètres des lieux fréquentés par des
enfants
à Miami un seul endroit répond aux
exigences de cette loi un hangar
désaffecté perdu en plein no man's land
industriel au fin fond du quartier
d'aïkalia le quartier hispanique du
Nord-Ouest Miami
[Musique]
une seule association aux sportifs
des religieux les bâtisses du Mont Sion
tous les samedis soirs il leur sert à
manger mais surtout ils les font prier
votre attention s'il vous plaît on a des
bibles pour vous Miami oblige la lecture
de la Bible se fait dans les deux
langues anglais et espagnol
Jésus Jésus juste parmi les justes
Jésus entend tout il entend vos peines
et vos prières il vous soutient
il faut lui faire confiance
[Musique]
l'heure du coucher approche le pasteur
swing distribue des couvertures
on leur redonne souvent des couvertures
puisque beaucoup d'entre eux n'ont nulle
part où les stocker
alors que certains dorment amènent le
sol d'autres amènent leur temps chaque
soir
et dis-lui peut compter sur sa voiture
il a fait 20 ans de prison pour volama
armé kidnapping de mineur une
condamnation qui le range dans la
catégorie des criminels sexuels une
décision qu'il accepte mal
ley voilà c'était si je dors
je vais me coucher là sur ce qui me sert
de lit j'ai mes draps il fait froid
c'est tout ce que je peux dire ça me
fait souffrir mais bon qu'est-ce que j'y
peux
ils m'ont même posé ça pour me
surveiller
comme tous les criminels sexuels de
Miami eddy est équipé d'un bracelet
électronique le temps de sa
conditionnelle il ne peut pas dormir
ailleurs qu'ici alors c'est le système D
Rumes c'est la vie mec
j'ai l'impression que c'est dur pour
vous d'assister à ça
oui c'est dur on traite les chiens mieux
que ça
il faut qu'on se réveille on est le pays
le plus riche au monde et là on a des
gens qui vivent dans la rue qui n'ont
plus rien
on espère que des politiques vont se
bouger il faut construire un endroit
pour eux
je sais que ce ne sont pas des anges et
c'est vrai que certains ont commis des
faits graves mais eux aussi ont droit à
un endroit pour vivre
[Musique]
la mise en une forme de double peine
pour ces hommes qui vivent ici comme
dans une prison assez Louvière
[Musique]
le lendemain matin il est 8 heures
quasiment tout le monde a des gueries
sauf Eddy qui s'apprête à partir au
travail
bonjour Eddy salut comment s'est passé
votre nuit vous allez bien dormir
[Musique]
parfois faut toujours se méfier bien
fermer sa voiture
les nuits sont parfois tendues
cette voiture c'est la planche de salut
dédie
j'ai inscrit le mot liberté parce que
bon on va dire que cette voiture j'y
mets de l'essence et c'est la liberté
c'est une sorte de symbole
et ici j'ai mis vie
pourquoi parce que je crois en Dieu
et aussi parce que quand j'ouvre cette
porte c'est la vie c'est ma vie mes
croyances
voilà
et vous trouvez le temps long
j'essaie de m'occuper de ne pas y penser
et j'attends surtout que ça se termine
dans 6 mois normalement je tournerai la
page
mais oui ça me fait beaucoup souffrir au
plus profond de moi
j'espère que ça ira un jour ou l'autre
ça ira
[Musique]
Eddy a encore six mois à tenir sur ce
parking ensuite il loua sans doute un
appartement pour lequel il sera obligé
de se déclarer criminel sexuel
[Musique]
plus mon séjour avance plus la violence
de cette ville me saute aux yeux
les crimes et les drames remplissent
tous les journaux
j'ai rendez-vous dans une institution le
mi-amirald
c'est l'un des cinq plus grands
quotidiens du pays
en un peu plus d'un siècle le journal a
reçu 19 prix plus
sont chroniqueur judiciaire en est
plutôt fier
bonjour David bonjour bienvenue ça va
vous rencontrer ça va bien merci
bienvenue dans notre rédaction c'est le
service société ici on est en pleine
activité aujourd'hui
là il y a la conférence de rédaction en
ce moment
toutes les télévisions locales qui nous
tiennent au courant de l'actualité
vous avez choisi le bon moment pour
venir
en tant que journaliste quand vous
travaillez sur un sujet comment
l'abordez-vous exactement
il faut déjà que je trouve des histoires
particulières qui symbolise la
singularité de Miami
du coup j'aime bien les histoires
concernant des gens ou des comportements
dont on ignore parfois l'existence
ici il y a plein d'histoires étranges
très bizarres que j'aime bien faire
découvrir
la folie criminelle qui caractérise
Miami c'est au palais de justice qu'elle
est criante
[Musique]
David Yva tous les jours des dizaines de
procès ont lieu
pour trouver l'histoire marquante il
passe son temps à pousser les portes des
salles d'audience
[Musique]
derrière ses murs c'est toute la société
et les communautés de Miami qui défilent
ici des membres de gants comparaissent
pour braquage à main armée
là deux frères cubains sont accusés
d'avoir tué un homme pour mettre la main
sur son élevage de pigeons
mais l'histoire que retiendra
aujourd'hui David
c'est l'épilogue d'un long marathon
judiciaire
[Musique]
est-ce que coupable d'avoir drogué battu
étrangler sa femme de 21 ans Wendy
trapago il venait juste de l'épouser
trois jours plus tôt avant qu'il ne la
tue et abandonne son corps sur le
parking d'un entrepôt
c'était il y a quelques mois Michel
escotto reconnu coupable d'un crime
crapuleux l'assassinat de sa femme pour
toucher une assurance vie d'un million
de dollars
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est la dernière étape de
ce procès Michel escauto va recevoir sa
sentence définitive un moment attendu
avec impatience par la famille de la
victime mais aussi par David qui finit
là le plus long procès de sa carrière
c'est une histoire que je suis depuis 12
ans quand Wendy trapago a été tué
en fait je venais d'arriver au Miami et
rald
depuis j'ai suivi l'enquête le procès et
aujourd'hui la sentence
c'est un moment très émouvant et assez
tragique
le condamné fait son entrée il a
toujours quemé son innocence malgré
l'épreuve accablante retenue contre lui
et ses avocats sont seuls face à une
famille en deuil
mesdames messieurs bonjour Aujourd'hui
fin du procès escauto
avocat veuillez présenter vos clients
s'il vous plaît
chacun leur tour famille et amis
défilent à la barre pour dire tout le
mal qu'il pense du condamné
j'aurais aimé la peine de mort pour toi
mais il faudra que je vive avec cette
décision
l'accusé reste impassible
[Musique]
c'est ensuite autour de la mère de la
victime de prendre la parole
d'origine cubaine elle s'exprime en
espagnol avec l'aide d'un traducteur
elle est bouleversée
elle ne méritait pas cela
elle était la dernière personne à
mériter cette fin
tu ne sais pas ce que tu as perdu
tu faisais partie de notre famille
[Musique]
cette famille qui était unie autour de
toi
[Musique]
parce que ma fille t'aimait et elle
était heureuse
et on était prêt à t'aimer aussi
mais ton ambition était plus forte
tu vas avoir beaucoup de temps
pour réfléchir à ton acte
et j'espère qu'un jour
tu te repentiras
et que Dieu te pardonnera
pour tout le mal que tu as fait
et pour tous ceux que tu as fait
souffrir
merci
[Musique]
comme le veut la tradition le condamné
s'adresse en dernier à l'Assemblée
certains faits peuvent être prouvés
d'autres sont très difficiles à prouver
ce sera mon fardeau de vivre avec cette
vérité
mais je peux vous assurer que je
comprends pas les enquêteurs mais vous
la famille je comprends que votre
douleur vous fasse dire
tant de choses injustes
car moi je connais au moins une partie
de la vérité
merci
monsieur
selon l'article 9 21 de l'État de
Floride vous êtes condamné à la prison à
vie sans appel
merci
[Musique]
Michel escotto échappe à la peine de
mort en vigueur en Floride mais il
finira sa vie en prison une satisfaction
pour la famille de la victime
je suis ravie c'est un merveilleux jour
pour moi
un grand jour aussi pour les médias
David est aux premières loges
merci à tous les médias pour votre
soutien
et pour avoir raconté notre histoire
je voulais juste vous saluer
je vous remercie pour tout ce que vous
avez fait pour moi
pour David l'instant era il a toujours
cru à la culpabilité de l'accusé et
soutenu la famille
oui je reste toujours en contact avec
les familles
il faut que je file pour mon papier
David par écrire son dernier article sur
l'affaire escotto avant de revenir
demain déambuler dans ses couloirs où
bat le bout de la société de Miami
[Musique]
les dernières heures de mon séjour à
Miami je les passerai à Liberty City le
quartier des bal perdu
[Musique]
comme dans de nombreux ghettos des
États-Unis on en trouve à peu près tous
les 200 mètres
de toutes les confessions
nous sommes dimanche matin je me rends
dans l'une de ces paroisses où l'on
pense ses plaies en souriant
a priori je suis la seule blanche et
l'église est déjà en ébullition
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le mont calvaire est une église baptiste
une confession qui représente un
Américain sur 5 ici on marche dans les
pas de Martin Luther King mais la vraie
star aujourd'hui c'est lui le pasteur
strange
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le révérence strange et le pasteur de
cette communauté depuis 25 ans
l'audience bois littéralement ses
paroles
est-ce que vous êtes avec moi vous êtes
avec moi
bon le gouvernement peut parfois nous
aider pour ce qui touche à nos
difficultés matérielles
par exemple la nourriture vous êtes
toujours avec moi
mais il y a des besoins dans nos vies
pour lesquels le gouvernement ne peut
rien faire
[Applaudissements]
transporter dans un autre monde
les femmes sont sur leur drapeau ils
sont assez loin de leur quotidien
au fil de son sermon le pasteur fait
monter la pression
la transe s'empare de lui et du public
[Musique]
vous demandez comment vous allez comment
je me sens oui là maintenant béni j'aime
Dieu
c'est pour ça que je viens vers vous je
me sens tellement mieux vous sentez bien
oui
[Musique]
le pasteur lui aussi a l'air plutôt bien
le pasteur vous aide aussi vous et les
familles du quartier oui c'est un homme
puissant
lui aussi je l'aime
[Musique]
faut pas faire le show le pasteur
strange procède au bénédiction après 3
heures d'office
en imposant ses mains l'Esprit Saint
s'empare de l'esprit des paroissiens et
efface leur mauvaise pensée jusqu'à
l'évanouissement
je dois te dire Dieu est en moi
tu vas sentir une énergie ça va être
chaud ça va être chaud il arrive ça
vient il arrive
[Musique]
c'était très impressionnant vraiment
vous savez nous avons de longs services
pourquoi tant de pleurs tant de larmes
tout le monde est si ému ici
je touche le rémotivité
cela fait partie du processus de
régénération c'est mon objectif pendant
mes serments
[Musique]
priez Dieu je l'aime aussi comment vous
sentez-vous là je suis épuisé oui je
peux imaginer
j'ai besoin d'un jour ou deux pour faire
redescendre la pression
merci beaucoup pour votre accueil merci
à vous merci à vous profitez bien et
Dieu vous bénisse c'était une joie
mon séjour s'achève
je repars d'ici avec un sentiment mitigé
aujourd'hui à Miami il y a deux fois
moins de morts aux heures sombres de
Pablo Escobar
Miami Beach et les beaux quartiers n'ont
jamais été aussi sûr mais la violence
elle s'est emparée des ghettos
[Musique]
où il n'y a guère que les prières pour
stopper les balles perdues